.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Dass wir hier etwas für unsere
Zukunft tun können, ist megacool.
Es musste so sein.
- Genau, es musste so sein.
Als ich die Zahl sah,
musste ich sagen: "No way."
Nun schauen wir mal,
was der Architekt sagt.
Der Rasenmäher
ist das Beste an diesem Haus.
Grundsätzlich
raten uns viele zu einem Neubau.
Aber die müssen es alle
nicht bezahlen.
Das muss man sich mal
vor Augen führen:
Seit wir
mit diesem Projekt begannen,
haben sich die Hypothekarzinsen
zweitweise verdreifacht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das ist die absolute Überforderung.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ramona und Raphael gehören
zu einer Minderheit in der Schweiz:
Mit 31 Jahren können sich die
Lehrerin und der Unternehmensberater
ihren grossen Traum vom eigenen Haus
erfüllen.
Einerseits
war es natürlich total schön.
Wir haben uns sehr gefreut,
dass wir das Haus bekommen haben
und dass wir
unseren Traum verwirklichen können.
Andererseits sehen wir auch
die Arbeit, die nun auf uns zukommt.
Zuerst dachten wir: "Okay, gut,
jetzt haben wir das Haus."
Und dann: "Was?"
Das Haus - Baujahr 1951 -
hat schon bessere Tage gesehen.
Willkommen.
Ramona und Raphael
ziehen noch nicht ein.
Zuerst wollen sie
das alte Haus renovieren.
Etwas mehr Licht.
Ich finde z.B. diese Eckbank schön
und würde sie gern
wieder integrieren -
sei es hier oder anderswo.
Das kann ich mir
gar nicht vorstellen.
Den Fliesenboden im Eingangsbereich
und in der Küche
finde ich auch schön.
Ramonas erste Aussage war:
"Oh, ein megaschöner Boden."
Ich meinte: "Hm, zum Schachspielen,
aber im Haus
vielleicht nicht unbedingt."
Man sieht relativ gut,
dass es hier ziemlich eng ist.
Wenn sie die Tür öffnet
und ich hinter ihr stehe,
muss ich zur Seite gehen.
Ja.
Aber hier würden wir die Tür
vielleicht so montieren,
dass sie sich
auf die andere Seite öffnet.
Was?
- Nicht?
Auf die andere Seite?
- So, weisst du.
Das ist doch völlig kontraintuitiv.
- Wieso?
Man öffnet eine Tür doch nicht so.
Das ist nur in England so.
Hä? Schau, Raphi, ich zeige es dir.
* Sie lacht. *
So.
Ah, aber der Türgriff
ist auch auf derselben Seite.
Das meine ich.
Nein, aber hier ...
Stimmt, wenn man
auf der anderen Seite steht, nicht.
Okay, 1:0.
Die Tatsache, dass wir hier etwas
für unsere Zukunft tun können,
ist megacool.
Es ist toll,
gemeinsam ein Haus zu besitzen,
eine Familie zu gründen
und etwas Eigenes zu haben.
Es musste so sein.
- Genau, es musste so sein.
Ihr neues Zuhause steht im Aargau,
im Heimatkanton der beiden.
Einen Steinwurf entfernt
wohnt auch die Schwester von Ramona.
Wir haben 750'000 Fr. bezahlt.
Ja.
Inklusive Grundstück.
Es sind 703 m2.
704 m2.
- Ah, 704 m2, okay.
Das Haus hat eine Fläche
von ungefähr 130 m2.
Bis jetzt
haben wir alles selbst finanziert.
Eines der Mantras meines Vaters
war schon in meiner Kindheit,
dass man die Fixkosten
tief halten sollte.
Ich glaube,
wir sind beide sehr sparsam.- Mhm.
Und wir verdienen beide relativ gut.
Und diese Kombination ...
Ja.- ... ist praktisch,
wenn man ein Haus kaufen will.
* Dynamische Musik *
Das ist fast das Prunkstück,
wenn man so will:
unser Garten.
Ja, er ist riesig.
Später steht hier
vielleicht mal ein Pool.
Das wird im Winter
unser Weihnachtsbaum.
Er steht bereits hier.
Mir persönlich war es beim Kauf
bzw. der Suche nach einem Haus
sehr wichtig,
dass genügend Platz vorhanden ist.
Ich glaube, das wird in Zukunft
immer schwieriger zu finden sein.
Deshalb sind wir sehr froh,
dass ein so grosses Grundstück
dazugehört.
Auf ihrem Weg zum Eigenheim
wird das junge Paar
von Raphaels Eltern unterstützt.
Ich habe noch zwei Geschwister
und unsere Eltern
gaben allen je 100'000 Fr.,
damit wir uns ein Haus
oder eine Wohnung kaufen können.
Sie wollten uns das
auch ermöglichen.
Wir haben das Glück, dass wir das
Geld bisher nicht gebraucht haben.
Ja, das ist unser Haus.
Mhm. Ich bin gespannt,
wie es in einem Jahr aussieht.
Das alte Haus
ist zwar noch nicht bewohnbar,
doch die beiden können froh sein,
überhaupt eines bekommen zu haben.
Der Schweizer Immobilienmarkt
ist vollkommen überhitzt.
* Ruhige Musik *
Luzern - hier wohnt das Paar.
Mit 1'650 Fr. im Monat
sind ihre Mietkosten überschaubar.
Hier habe ich jetzt
unser Haus hochgeladen.
Nun sieht man es als 3-D-Modell.
Man kann es sich
von allen Seiten anschauen.
Alles dreht sich
um ihr Haus im Aargau.
Mit viel Enthusiasmus
planen sie den Umbau.
Wir würden natürlich gern
so rasch wie möglich einziehen,
aber unser Leben hier
gefällt mir eigentlich.
Ich habe es nicht eilig,
hier wegzukommen.
Wir bezahlen ja extrem wenig Zins.
Darum haben wir es nicht eilig.
Wenn man dagegen extrem viel bezahlt
und eine Doppelbelastung besteht,
hat man es eiliger und
kann sich nicht so viel Zeit lassen.
Ich finde es nicht so toll,
dass es glänzt.
Ja, das gefällt mir auch nicht so.
- Lieber matt.
Die Frage ist auch, ob wir
in der Küche einen Holzboden wollen.
(Seufzend) Das ist eine der Fragen.
Momente, in denen wir
etwas überfordert sind,
gibt es etwa jeden zweiten Tag.
Es gibt immer Hochs und Tiefs.
Jetzt bin ich
gerade wieder in einem Hoch.
Aber manchmal habe ich schon Tiefs,
in denen ich mich vor der vielen
Arbeit fürchte, die auf uns zukommt.
Es ist ja auch etwas Schönes
und einiges mache ich auch gern,
aber manchmal
kann es zu viel werden.
* Dynamische Musik *
Digitale Beratungsagentur Luzern:
Hier arbeitet Raphael zusammen mit
dem Firmeninhaber Klaus Oberholzer.
Die beiden unterstützen Kunden,
die den Umsatz ihrer Onlinefirmen
steigern wollen.
Sie sind nicht ganz deckungsgleich,
aber ...
Genau,
aber hier müssten wir überlegen,
ob wir den Input nicht links
und den Output rechts haben wollen.
(Lachend) Ja, von mir aus.
Auf diese Dinge legst du
jeweils auch grossen Wert.- Stimmt.
Raphi ist ...
Er sagte mal über sich,
er sei wie ein Stein.
Damit hat er nicht unrecht.
Wir beschrieben ihn im Team
jeweils als 60-jährigen Bünzli
im Körper eines 30-Jährigen.
Er bestritt das gar nie,
sondern fand es sogar cool.
Daran erinnere ich mich.
Was ist so schlecht daran,
ein Bünzli zu sein?
Wenn man ein Bünzli ist,
hat man alles,
was man zum Glücklichsein braucht.
Dass man ein Haus bauen,
eine Familie gründen
und sesshaft werden will,
finde ich grossartig.
Es ist, als hättest du mit 16
einen Aufsatz geschrieben,
wo du mit 35 sein willst
und nun arbeitest du das
checklistenmässig ab.
Checklisten
sind auch extrem effektiv.
Er hat nicht mal widersprochen.
* Dynamische Musik *
Der erste Termin
mit ihrem Architekten steht an.
Die Neu-Hausbesitzer
nehmen den öffentlichen Verkehr.
Ein Auto haben sie nicht.
Das ist unser Moodboard,
wenn man es so nennen will.
Es enthält Ideen und Dinge,
die wir gut finden.
Diese Bilder habe ich ausgesucht
und diese Bilder
hat Raphi ausgesucht.
Haben wir eigentlich
Überschneidungen?
Nein.
Aber das hier ...
Ein Cheminée als Wohnraumtrenner
habe ich auch irgendwo, glaube ich.
Ich finde das ziemlich stylish.
- Mhm, das sah ich auch.
Findest du das nicht geil?
Nein,
das sieht zu sehr nach Hotel aus.
Das hier ist mir etwas zu dunkel,
aber mit einem Kleinen
finde ich es cool.
Tja ...
- Ich finde das gut.
Ich habe irgendwie noch keinen Plan.
Wir haben ein paar Bilder
ausgesucht, aber ...
... ich würde daraus
kein Haus bauen wollen.
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt,
was er zum Haus sagt.
Ob er findet, dass es keinen Sinn
macht, es stehen zu lassen,
oder ob er uns empfiehlt,
gewisse Dinge nicht abzureissen
und etwas anderes daraus zu machen.
Ich bin sehr
auf seine Meinung gespannt.
Mhm.
Ich glaube, er will es abreissen.
Mal sehen.
Ja.
Für die Suche nach dem geeigneten
Architekten nahmen sie sich Zeit.
Es war ihnen wichtig,
dass er ihre individuellen
Bedürfnisse berücksichtigt.
Noch sind sie sich unsicher,
ob sie das Haus renovieren
oder abreissen
und ein neues Haus bauen sollen.
Hallo, Carol.
- Hallo zusammen.- Hallo.
Hallo.
Architekt Carol Egger
sieht das alte Haus zum ersten Mal.
Wir haben tolles Wetter ausgewählt.
- Ja, das haben wir so bestellt.
Was war das mal?
- Ein Kamin.
Darin stand der Ofen.
- Okay.
Das ist der Grundriss.
Es ist alles relativ klein
und ziemlich schmal.
Ja.
- Und ... äh ...
Ursprünglich wollten wir diese Wand
entfernen und anbauen.
Nachdem wir es ausgerechnet hatten,
hatten wir den Eindruck,
dass wir doch noch einen Neubau
in Betracht ziehen müssen.
Mhm.
Das Erdgeschoss und das Dachgeschoss
zu übernehmen, ist kein Thema?
Nein.
- Ja ...
Bei einem Umbau werden die Kosten
sicher gleich hoch sein,
denn man muss alles renovieren.
Eben. Mir war es wichtig,
deine Meinung zu hören.
Nein, das ist ...
Wenn man es umbaut,
macht man quasi einen Neubau.
Ui, ui, ui! Hast du den Schlüssel?
Es ist schon wichtig,
dass man in den Garten kommt.- Ja.
Der Rasenmäher
ist das Beste an diesem Haus.
* Alle lachen. *
Wahrscheinlich das Einzige,
was noch funktioniert.
Es ist okay.
Wir haben uns damit abgefunden.
Nein, wir wussten ja,
was wir kaufen - mehr oder weniger.
Klar.
So gut man das halt beurteilen kann.
- Als Laie.
Renovation oder Neubau?
Eine schwierige Entscheidung.
Die Tage des alten Hauses im Aargau
scheinen gezählt.
In ihrer Mietwohnung in Luzern
brüten Ramona und Raphael
über den Bauplänen.
Die Überlegung war mal - also,
keine ernsthafte Überlegung ...
(Lachend) Willst du wirklich
deine Skizzen zeigen?
... wenn wir
einen Umbau gemacht hätten.
Wenn man ein Haus umbaut,
wird es von der Bank
nie so hoch bewertet wie ein Neubau,
auch wenn man
gleich viel Geld investiert,
weil es halt immer noch
ein altes Haus ist.
Grundsätzlich
raten uns viele zu einem Neubau.
Aber die müssen es alle
nicht bezahlen.
Das muss man auch noch dazu sagen.
Für Aussenstehende ergibt ein Neubau
wirtschaftlich gesehen mehr Sinn.
Für uns ist es jedoch so,
dass wir uns einen Umbau
relativ gut hätten leisten können.
Wenn wir einen Neubau machen,
bleibt uns danach
nicht mehr viel übrig.
Wir haben es durchgerechnet:
Wir können es finanzieren ...
Knapp.
- ... aber dann bleibt ...
... nicht mehr viel übrig.
- Gar nichts mehr.
Trotz des finanziellen Risikos
entscheiden sich die beiden
Anfangsdreissiger für einen Neubau.
Zusammen mit dem Architekten
machen sie sich jetzt an die Planung.
Als Erstes würde ich versuchen,
das Raumprogramm festzulegen.
Grundsätzlich
geht man von einem Programm aus.
D.h., wie viele Zimmer wollt ihr
und wie gross sollen sie sein?
Habt ihr noch nicht
so genau darüber nachgedacht?
Nein, das haben wir
noch nicht so ... Also ...
Ich habe mir überlegt,
dass mittel- bis langfristig
ein Gästezimmer ein Thema wäre.
Wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass wir mal zwei Kinder haben ...
Mehr sicher nicht, ausser es gibt
beim zweiten Mal Zwillinge.
Mit dem Büro, zwei Kinderzimmern
und unserem Schlafzimmer
sind wir dann halt am Limit.
Dann machen wir ein Zimmer mehr.
- Mhm. Und ... ähm ...
Das war jetzt ganz einfach:
"Also gut, ein Zimmer mehr."
Ihr bestimmt das Raumprogramm.
Ihr könnt so viele Zimmer machen,
wie ihr wollt.
Ich komme auf ungefähr 94 m2.
Okay.- Das ist die Wohnfläche
im Obergeschoss.
* Dynamische Musik *
Und dann ist die Frage,
was im Untergeschoss passiert.
Mhm.
Ist es für euch ein Thema,
das Untergeschoss zu minimieren?
Ihr habt euer Budget ja auf ungefähr
800'000 Fr. festgelegt.- Mhm.
Ich sagte euch von Anfang an,
dass man sich mit diesem Budget
etwas einfallen lassen muss.
Ich sage immer, dass ein
Einfamilienhaus 1 Mio. Fr. kostet.
800'000 Fr.
sind halt schon ein geringes Budget.
Entweder baut man einfach eine Box
mit Untergeschoss -
dann kriegt man das irgendwie hin -
oder man baut etwas Besonderes.
Ich hätte den Anspruch,
etwas Besonderes zu bauen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es euch geht.
Dann muss man halt
Kompromisse eingehen.- Mhm.
Das alte Häuschen wird also definitiv
einem Neubau weichen müssen.
Um sich diesen leisten zu können,
muss das junge Paar viel Geld sparen.
Schon als wir im Kindergarten waren,
begann unsere Mutter,
uns pro Woche 10 oder 20 Rp.
Taschengeld zu geben.
Das war enorm wenig, aber so
lernten wir, mit Geld umzugehen.
Wir mussten uns entscheiden,
ob wir wirklich
bestimmte Süssigkeiten kaufen
oder lieber auf etwas Grösseres
sparen wollten.
Ich bin enorm dankbar,
dass das so war.
Deshalb habe ich keine grossen
Probleme, mit Geld umzugehen.
Mit nur 33 Jahren
schafften es die Doppelverdiener,
Eigenkapital von 400'000 Fr.
auf die Seite zu legen.
Seit sie einen Neubau planen,
führt Raphael eine Excel-Liste,
um die Kosten im Griff zu behalten.
Wenn man auf irgendetwas spart,
denkt man immer,
man müsse beim Einkauf
darauf achten,
eine noch günstigere Variante
eines Produkts zu wählen.
Aber letztlich
sind das nicht die Dinge,
die wirklich ins Gewicht fallen.
Es hängt viel eher davon ab,
ob man bei den Mietkosten oder bei
der Hypothek noch etwas machen kann.
Die Liste hat uns sehr geholfen,
ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
wo die Stellschrauben sind,
an denen wir noch drehen können.
Das Haus ist für uns
eine riesige Investition.
Bevor wir
mit dem Projekt weitermachten,
mussten wir uns deshalb sicher sein,
dass wir es uns
wirklich leisten können.
Nicht, dass uns mittendrin
das Geld ausgeht.
Aber bis jetzt
sieht es relativ gut aus.
Wir gaben sogar
etwas weniger Geld aus,
als wir budgetiert hatten.
Zurück im Kanton Aargau:
Um einen umfassenderen Eindruck
vom Werk des Architekten zu bekommen,
besichtigen Ramona und Raphael
ein Haus,
das Carol Egger für
eine holländische Familie gebaut hat.
Wie geht's?
- (Frau) Alles gut.- Super.
(Ramona) Schön.
- Fasst mal den Liapor-Beton an.
Sehr hohe Räume.
Megatoll.
Du hast einen guten Job gemacht.
Die Treppe ist
nicht ganz absturzsicher.- Stimmt.
(Frau)
Bis jetzt ist nichts passiert.
Hoffentlich bleibt es so.
Das ist das Cheminée, das ...
Der Kamin geht hier rüber
und dann hier hoch.- Okay.
Schön.
(Frau)
Anfangs war es schon spannend.
Bezüglich der Wand sagte ich:
"So viele Löcher!
Muss man die nicht schliessen?"
Nicht wahr? Aber jetzt finde ich
diese Wand fast am schönsten.
Ja, jetzt finden wir sie auch schön.
So schön.
- Man gewöhnt sich daran.
Man findet sie normal
und sie wirkt warm.
(Ramona) Das ist megacool.
Diese hohe Schiebetür
ist auch megatoll.
Die finde ich auch sehr schön.
Total schön.
Wow, Carol, sehr schön.
Ich freue mich.
Ich bin so froh,
dass wir dich ausgewählt haben.
Wir stehen noch am Anfang,
aber ich freue mich sehr.
Sehr schön.
- Das bestärkt mich.
Es ging nicht so schnell,
einen Architekten zu finden,
auf den man sich verlassen kann
und mit dem die Zusammenarbeit
gut klappt.
Eineinhalb Monate später
präsentiert Carol Egger
in seinem Architekturbüro in Luzern
die ersten Entwürfe.
Also, Tür auf:
Man kommt hier rein.
So entsteht ein räumliches Gefühl.
Man kommt rein,
geht die Treppe hoch ...
Diese Feuerstelle
dient als Raumtrenner.
Wenn man hier vorn steht, öffnet
sich der Gang nach hinten leicht.
Dann gehen wir mal hoch.
Hier hinten ist das Badezimmer
und dort euer grosses Schlafzimmer.
Megatoll.
Es sieht sehr interessant aus.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich finde es megatoll, aber
wenn ich mir das Budget anschaue ...
Wir geben ja relativ viel Geld
für die Fassade,
die Form und die Fenster aus.
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon,
aber das geht mir
einfach durch den Kopf.
Ich frage mich, ob es nicht ...
- Mhm.
Kompakter, meinst du?
- Ja, einfach ...
Dafür noch einen Keller.
Mir ist der Keller ziemlich wichtig.
Das Thema ist ja immer noch,
wie wir 200'000 Fr. einsparen.
* Lachen *
Diese Variante
ist noch nicht ganz fertig geplant,
aber man sieht, was mit einem total
kompakten Volumen machbar wäre.
Quasi ein Punkthaus,
wie es dort einige bauen werden.
Es ist natürlich eine Gratwanderung.
Wir wollen kein normales
Einfamilienhaus bauen ...
* Er lacht. *
... oder ich zumindest nicht.
* Lachen *
Tja ...
Ich habe nicht per se etwas
gegen ein normales Einfamilienhaus.
Klar, es muss uns gefallen ...
... aber letztlich
leben wir primär drinnen.
Also ...
Ich sagte von Anfang an,
dass ich kein Architekt bin,
der ein Einfamilienhaus
aus der Schublade zieht,
um es dann genau so zu bauen.
Aber wenn du sagst,
dass du genau das willst,
was dort steht,
dann muss man eigentlich
nicht mehr kreativ sein,
sondern das Ganze einfach planen
und ausführen.
Ja.
Hm!
Ja, ich bin ...
Ich kann nicht so schnell
Entscheidungen treffen.
Ich ändere es kurz, okay?
- Das ist schon auch cool.
Anpassungen gibt es immer,
insbesondere
bei einem Einfamilienhaus.
Ein Einfamilienhaus baut man
nur einmal und es ist völlig klar,
dass man unzählige Ideen hat
und alles will.
Meistens
braucht es schon etwas Zeit,
bis man beim finalen Grundriss
angelangt ist.
Oft landet man wieder dort,
wo man anfangs war.
Das erlebe ich oft.
* Raphael und Ramona lachen. *
Die erste Begeisterung ist verflogen.
Die Planung entpuppt sich
als nervenaufreibende Sache.
Auch Monate später
steht das Haus im Aargau noch immer.
* Ruhige Musik *
Hypothekarzinsen und Preise
für Baumaterialien steigen ohne Ende.
Es scheint der ungünstigste Zeitpunkt
zu sein,
um mit knappem Budget
ein Haus bauen zu wollen.
* Seufzen *
Als wir die Kostenschätzung
erhielten und sahen,
dass wir 230'000 Fr.
über unserem Budget liegen,
brauchten wir beide
eine kurze Pause.
Diese Pause war nötig, damit wir
die Freude nicht verlieren,
denn das war schon
eine niederschmetternde Nachricht.
Das muss man sich mal
vor Augen führen:
Seit wir
mit diesem Projekt begannen,
haben sich die Hypothekarzinsen
zeitweise verdreifacht.
Wenn man das auf eine
zehnjährige Hypothek hochrechnet,
mit den Beträgen, die wir benötigen,
um ein neues Haus zu bauen,
geht es um mehrere 10'000 Fr.,
die wir haben oder nicht haben.
Wir wollen uns mit diesem Haus
nicht selbst
in den finanziellen Ruin treiben.
Es ist
eine relativ einfache Geschichte:
Wir machen das nur,
wenn wir sicher sind,
dass wir es finanzieren können.
* Dynamische Musik *
Luzern.
Raphael hat ein preiswertes Hobby:
Er joggt -
gerne mit einem Ziel vor Augen.
Die Teilnahme
am SwissCityHalbmarathon.
Beim Halbmarathon weiss man ziemlich
genau, worauf man sich einlässt:
Man weiss, wie lange er dauert
und wo es langgeht.
Beim Haus glaubt man zu wissen,
wo es langgeht,
aber dann kommt jemand und sagt:
"Das müsst ihr auch noch machen."
"Dort gibt es noch das
und dort noch jenes."
Am Ende ist man an einem
ganz anderen Ort als zu Beginn.
(Speaker) 15 Sek.,
fifteen seconds to go.
Wir zählen gemeinsam rückwärts:
(Alle)
Zehn, neun, acht, sieben, sechs,
fünf, vier, drei, zwei,
eins und go!
* Jubel, Applaus *
* Dynamische Musik *
(Frau) Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp!
Raphael beweist,
dass er Ausdauer hat.
Einen langen Atem braucht er auch
bei seinem Traum vom Eigenheim.
Die Planung zieht sich seit
einem halben Jahr schleppend dahin.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Die 21,1 km des Halbmarathons
schafft er in 1 Std. 53 Min. -
unter dem angestrebten Ziel
von 2 Std.
Das Haus im Aargau
steht auch ein Jahr nach dem Kauf
noch unbewohnt und verlassen da.
Die Situation auf dem Baumarkt
hat sich weiter verschärft:
Energiekrise und Teuerung treiben
die Kosten weiter in die Höhe.
Wollen wir mal
über die Kosten sprechen?- Okay.
Im neuen Jahr
ist alles um 30 % gestiegen.
Schon wieder?
- Nein.
Der Beton, nicht wahr?
In den letzten drei bis vier Monaten
stiegen die Materialkosten
tatsächlich um 30-40 %.
Auch Unternehmer, die schon länger
im Geschäft sind als ich, sagten,
dass sie das noch nie erlebt hätten.
Es tut ein bisschen weh,
dass man keinen Mehrwert hat.
Es kostet mehr, aber man kriegt
das Gleiche wie die Leute,
die vor zwei Jahren bauten.
Es kostet einfach dreimal mehr.
Und ...
- Ich finde es auch etwas unfair.
Nein, es ist ...
Es tut wirklich weh,
aber andererseits
sind das wirklich Luxusprobleme.
Insbesondere
in der jetzigen Situation,
wenn man bedenkt, wieso es dazu kam,
fände ich es vermessen,
auf die Tränendrüse zu drücken.
Es ist immer noch ein totaler Luxus,
dass wir überhaupt
über solche Dinge reden können.
Ich würde heute
nicht mehr behaupten,
dass man für 1 Mio.
ein Haus bauen kann -
angesichts der Ansprüche,
die ihr habt,
und angesichts
der angestrebten Flächen.
Ihr habt immerhin
einige Quadratmeter Wohnfläche.
Gibt es irgendwo
noch eine Möglichkeit,
die Fläche zu reduzieren?
Ich würde sagen,
wir gehen in Ruhe die Liste durch
und schauen,
wo wir noch reduzieren können.
Die Zitrone
noch etwas weiter auspressen.- Oh!
Den ganzen Keller wegzulassen
wäre natürlich eine Lösung.- Hm!
Wir müssen bei jeder Position
ein bisschen sparen,
oder ihr entscheidet euch
gegen den Keller,
dann könnt ihr machen,
was ihr wollt.
* Lachen *
Ich finde den Grundriss
halt schon megacool.
Daher fände ich es schön,
wenn wir es so bauen könnten.
* Raphael seufzt. *
Okay.
Also, ich habe das Gefühl,
wenn wir es noch so anpassen können,
dass wir die besprochenen Dinge
hinzufügen
und das Volumen
ein bisschen reduzieren können,
ohne den Grundriss
zu kompromittieren,
kommen wir
auf eine vernünftige Zahl.
Fast niemand geht so super
vorbereitet zur Bank wie du.
Das ist ein bisschen mein Ding.
* Lachen *
Mir wäre es lieber,
später zur Bank sagen zu können,
dass wir doch nicht alles brauchen.
Ja, ja.
Wir gingen mit dieser
Kostenschätzung zu den Banken.
Es gab zwei bis drei Banken,
die der Meinung waren,
dass es finanzierbar ist.
Dann ging es darum, mit ihnen
über die Konditionen zu diskutieren.
Insgesamt haben wir
1,2 Mio. aufgenommen,
was immer noch
ziemlich absurd klingt.
Es ist genug.
Wir haben bereits ausgerechnet,
wie wir das
möglichst bald zurückzahlen können,
damit wir
nicht so hoch verschuldet sind.
* Ruhige Musik *
Eineinhalb Jahre nach dem Kauf
ist die Planung fast abgeschlossen,
der Neubau finanziert und das Budget
nun doch höher als 1 Mio. Fr.
Ramona und Raphael
suchen sich eine Küche aus.
Das Paar hat einen Grund mehr,
ein Haus zu bauen.
Ramona ist schwanger.
D.h., ein Kinderzimmer
ist schon mal belegt.
Geheiratet haben wir auch noch,
seit wir uns das letzte Mal sahen.
D.h., jetzt ist
wirklich alles vorbereitet.
Nur das Haus fehlt noch.
- Das Haus fehlt noch.
Wenn das Haus steht,
müssen wir noch einen Baum pflanzen,
dann ist alles erledigt.
Diese mit Kunstharz beschichteten
Spanplatten sind Standard.
Mhm.
Und das hier ist Echtholz?
- Genau.
Die gefallen mir.
- Das ist Echtholz.
Aber hier
sind wir im teuersten Bereich.
Wie hoch ist Ihr Budget?
- Ja, das ... ähm ...
Es ist immer stärker gesunken.
Wir schauen mal, wo wir hinkommen.
- Er traut sich kaum, es zu sagen.
Wie?- Er traut sich kaum,
unser Budget zu nennen.
Also, gut.
Ja, das wird ganz anders aussehen.
* Lachen *
Ganz anders als das, was ...
- Das wäre spannend.
So etwas würde für mich niemals
infrage kommen.
Da werde ich mich
bestimmt durchsetzen.
Mir gefallen die etwas
dunkleren Töne tendenziell besser.
Ramona findet die helleren schöner.
Das ist die grundlegende Diskussion,
die wir immer haben -
eine der Diskussionen.
Eigentlich geht alles.
Das ist die absolute Überforderung.
Ich finde diese Kombi
oder diese schön.
Was?
Wir sind uns immer noch uneinig.
Daran hat sich wenig geändert,
aber meistens
setzte sie sich am Ende durch.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt wirklich nicht!
Doch, bei den kleinen Details schon.
- Aber bei den grossen nicht.
Das war halt ...
- Das sind dann keine Details.
... taktisch geschickt.
Bei den grossen Dingen
setztest du dich durch.
Im Sommer sind die Bauprofile
erstellt und das Gesuch eingereicht.
Jetzt müssen sie warten,
bis die Gemeinde grünes Licht gibt.
* Beschwingte Musik *
* Kuhglocken *
Auf einer Alp im Berner Oberland
geniessen Raphael und Ramona
Ferien zusammen mit ihrer Familie.
Sie sind jetzt zu dritt.
* Das Baby quengelt. *
Ei, ei, ei.
Super.
* Lachen *
Ich geniesse es. Es ist sehr schön.
Was für eine Konfitüre ist das?
- Himbeere.- Oh!
Es hat sich
ziemlich gut eingependelt.
An dieser Front läuft es megagut.
- Mhm.
Bezüglich Haus ...
- Beim Haus könnte es besser laufen.
Bezüglich Haus
ist nicht viel passiert.
Wir haben ziemlich viel gewartet.
Das Baugesuch
reichten wir schon vor Monaten ein,
aber es gab
immer wieder Verzögerungen
und wir mussten Verschiedenes
nachreichen.
Das Haus steht immer noch.
Eine unendliche Geschichte.
Ramona ist als jüngstes von
insgesamt sechs Kindern aufgewachsen.
Sie war immer sparsam.
Sie musste immer darauf achten,
dass das Geld reicht,
auch während des Studiums.
Es war schon unser Ziel,
ihnen beizubringen,
mit Geld umzugehen.
Und Raphi ist auch so.
Es ist praktisch,
wenn beide so sind.
So bringt man es zu etwas.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Ich habe gewonnen.
Seit ihrer Jugend
steht für Ramona und Raphael
der Traum vom Eigenheim im Zentrum.
Ein langer Weg
mit vielen Hindernissen.
Schau, dort sind Gleitschirmflieger.
Ja, jetzt sehe ich sie.
Sie sind zu viert, oder?
Das würde mich auch mal reizen.
Du darfst das nicht mehr machen,
du hast jetzt ein Kind.- Hallo?
Das ist eine Extremsportart.
Extremsportarten ...
Gleitschirmfliegen?
- Na klar.
So ein Quatsch!
Nein, nein.
- Dann wären wir getrennt ...
Nein.- ... wenn du mir
etwas vorschreiben würdest.
Noch während der Ferien auf der Alp
wird ihr Baugesuch publiziert.
Nach einem Monat ist klar:
Es gibt keine Einsprachen.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch
die Baubewilligung.
Ein weiterer Termin beim Architekten
steht an.
Heute ist die Innenarchitektin
und 3-D-Artistin dabei.
Wollen wir noch kurz
übers Aussenbild sprechen?
Mhm.- Bei der Fassade
haben wir jetzt mal ...
So soll es aussehen,
Ramonas und Raphaels Traumhaus.
Es ist kein Punkthaus,
sondern ein L-Haus.
Das ist schon mal super.
* Lachen *
Nein, ich finde, es hat doch ...
Ich finde es sehr spannend.
Es fügt sich auch schön
in die Siedlung ein
und momentan finde ich es
noch sehr schön - auch innen.
Wir haben noch
ein Rundumbild kreiert.- Oh!
Oh!
Diese Bilder
sehen die beiden zum ersten Mal.
Oh!
Oh, schau, sie visualisierten den
Platz, den wir mal machen wollen.
Hei!
Habt ihr das ganze Haus
visualisiert?
* Lachen *
(Frau) Nur das Erdgeschoss.
Wow!
Es ist schon cool,
wenn es visualisiert ist.
Dann kann man es sich
besser vorstellen.
Ja, es sieht um einiges cooler aus
als auf den Plänen.
* Carol lacht. *
Ja.
- Wow!
Normalerweise sind wir bekannt
für unsere Schnelligkeit.
Das ist echt ...
Sorry.- Wir sind normalerweise
sehr zackig unterwegs.
Ich glaube,
i h r  wart auch schnell.
Aber wenn ich es
mit anderen vergleiche,
ist es nicht so,
dass wir extrem lange brauchten.
Wir begannen schliesslich bei null.
Rückblickend betrachtet
war die grösste Herausforderung
die Finanzierung
in derart schwierigen Zeiten.
Die Unsicherheit,
wie sich das Ganze entwickelt,
und die Diskussionen mit den Banken.
Als einige Banken sagten, dass sie
es nicht finanzieren wollen,
gab es schon Momente,
in denen ich daran zweifelte,
dass das Ganze vernünftig ist.
Das war bei mir das Thema.
Daher war ich froh,
als dieser Teil geregelt war.
Es hat nun auch gereicht, ohne
das Pensionskassengeld einzusetzen.
Uns beiden wäre nicht wohl gewesen,
wenn wir Pensionskassengelder
hätten beziehen müssen.
Die brauchen wir für die Zukunft.
Zwei Jahre ist es nun her,
seit sie das alte Haus im Aargau
gekauft haben.
Bald soll es abgerissen werden.
Die junge Familie wünscht sich,
an Weihnachten 2024 einzuziehen.
In einem der umstrittensten Punkte
hat sich Ramona durchgesetzt:
Mama und Papa
gehen kurz in den Keller.
Du bleibst hier.
- Brr, ist das kalt.
Und es riecht wieder gut hier unten.
- Ja, sehr gut.
Nun müssen wir den Wasserstand
und den Strom ablesen.
Es wird also wieder
einen Keller geben.
Unglaublich,
wie viele Sicherungen es hier gibt.
So.
Ich hoffe, der neue Sicherungskasten
ist verständlicher.- Hm!
Wahrscheinlich gibt es dann
doppelt so viele Sicherungen.
Schau, da hängen noch ein paar.
Die sind sicher noch gut.
- Ja.
Isst du die noch?
Die ist sicher
schon lange abgelaufen.
Hervorragend!
Trotz aller Widrigkeiten:
Sie bereuen ihre Entscheidung
für einen Abriss nicht im Geringsten.
Das hier ist das Dach.
Siehst du? Das hier.
Ich freue mich einfach mega.
- Ich mich auch.
Ich meine, ich muss ehrlich sagen,
wir hängen beide
nicht extrem an diesem Haus.
Es war süss:
Alle Nachbarn,
mit denen wir sprachen, meinten:
"Abreissen ergibt mehr Sinn."
Zuerst wollten wir es
ja nicht abreissen
und dann schluckten alle leer.
Schau, dort ist ein Hornissennest
oder ein Wespennest.
Das ist doch gut.
So wird das Haus noch benutzt.
Es ist noch ein bisschen bewohnt.
Als wir es kauften,
dachten wir, wir würden es umbauen.
Wir hätten nie gedacht,
dass wir nach zwei Jahren
hier stehen und das Haus ...
... auch noch.
- ... noch genau gleich aussieht.
Aber andererseits ...
- Aber es ist okay.
Wir können uns auf das bevorstehende
Projekt und das Haus freuen,
das wir mitgestaltet haben.
Das ist auch schön.
* Geräusche aus dem Babyfon *
Ah, sie ist wach.
Ich schaue kurz nach.
* Tiefer Seufzer *
Unser Leben hat sich in
der Zwischenzeit ziemlich verändert.
* Ruhige Musik *
Legendär.
Ramonas und Raphaels Weg
zum Eigenheim:
lang und beschwerlich -
aber auch voller Hoffnung und
Vorfreude auf ihr eigenes Zuhause.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023